- [Narrator] Seeing a nearly 50 percent decrease
in population over the past decade,
this is the radiated tortoise.
Endemic to the dry southern
forests of Madagascar,
the radiated tortoise has
an amazingly long lifespan.
The oldest tortoise on record
reached an estimated 188 years old.
Their shell is domed and highly intricate,
with bright yellow star patterns
radiating outwards on each plate.
The shells have both
blood vessels and nerves.
Meaning that it can feel
when it's being touched.
The sharp decline in the
tortoise's population
is mostly due to hunting and
the black market pet trade.
In Madagascar, their meat
is considered a delicacy
and illegal poaching has
decimated wild populations.
Additionally, their distinctive
markings on their shells
have made them desirably as pets.
It's estimated that a staggering
quarter-of-a-million radiated tortoises
are harvested each year.
Conservationists estimate these animals
could go extinct in less than 20 years.
This is the radiated tortoise.